hey it's evan and uh i'm excited because
i got a new computer from dell it's an
xps 12 and it arrived today nina comes
home
and she's like what's in the box what's
in the box you got to open it up
like i can i gotta make a video we'll
make a video because i wanna see what's
in the box i wanna see the new doubt
she's sitting on the couch behind
shaking her head now but uh anyway so
this is me opening up my new uh laptop
and we'll see what it looks like okay so
the reason for the xps 12 is that it was
super small
and super portable and i wanted
something for when i was traveling
or when i'm not basically at my computer
to have all my stuff on and it looked
pretty sexy so let's open it up and see
what we got
nina is standing by all excited can't
wait to see
oh
uh
just put that
wow
this thing is nice
nina says the box is fancy
oh that's it wow
this thing is little yeah look at that
oh there we go look at that nice
that's it
got my plug in my computer
it's pretty light that's it something in
here
quick start guide
i always read the quick start guys read
your quick start guys people
so open it up
cool
that's pretty easy and then there's a
way to swivel this
how do you switch oh there oh cool oh
there you go
so you can pop that out
and then it becomes
a tablet it's pretty cool so i got to
get all my stuff loaded on here and
we'll see how she performs
uh that's done
stay tuned
keep believing
you guys like this video thumbs up and
we'll see you soon